Sometimes the act of pushing other
distractions away can help us to focus.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
Today, I want to talk about focus.
How do we stay focused
in language learning?
Uh, remember, if you enjoy these videos,
please subscribe, uh, click on the bell.
Click on the bell for notifications.
If you follow me on Spotify or
Apple Podcasts or elsewhere,
please leave a review.
Um, focus.
I get this question all the time.
People say they lose focus.
So how do we, how do we get focused?
How do we stay focused?
Um, it just turns out that in my
Persian learning, Uh, we were able to
get permission to use some podcasts by
a fellow called B Plus who, uh, does
sort of Farsi, Persian language, uh,
summaries of very popular self-help books.
So he did one on, uh, deep
learning uh deep work...
deep work, and one on focus...
Uh, and so I went back
to have a look at that.
I thought I wanted to see if there
was something there and I had gone
through them in Persian and didn't
find them that interesting actually.
And so, but then I went back and looked
at them again to look at them again, to
see if I could learn anything relevant.
Uh, right away I was more focused
cause I was interested in the
subject to see if there was anything
there that would be helpful in
addressing this whole issue of focus.
There wasn't because like so many of
these self-help books, it's just a lot
of common sense stuff packaged together
in a new format, you know: we need
to concentrate, we need to focus, uh,
and you know, taking some examples of
people in history who would isolate
themselves for two weeks at a time.
Bill Gates would go off to
his cottage or Jung the famous
psychologist or psychiatrist had a
chalet in Switzerland or something.
And, and certainly I remember, um, you
know, there are people in history, uh,
who was it, who had his tower that he...
Montaigne  who wrote essays in French.
He had his tower there somewhere down
in the Southwest of France where he
would go and he would be isolated.
And obviously if we can isolate
ourselves, that helps us concentrate.
But most people who are learning
languages, they can't take two
weeks off to go off somewhere.
If they have two weeks, they're
probably better off to go to the
country where the language is spoken.
So how do we focus in
on language learning?
Um, some so, and, and also, and this
comes up in both of these books and
it's something we're well aware of, the
modern sort of internet information age,
where we have access to information, we
have access to so much language content.
For example, we have access to,
you know, grammatically grammatical
explanations at the click of a
Google, uh, you know, uh, keystroke.
Um, and we have also access to, to an
audience for anything we want to do.
Like right now I'm talking
to people I don't know.
So this is a new world and
there's good and there's bad.
And the good is, yeah, we can access
so many things and we can get our
messages, so many people, and we
can learn so many things quickly.
If I, if I'm doing something in
Persian and they refer to a certain
dynasty and the history of Persia,
then I can go and click Wikipedia
and, and read it in English, which
is easier for me to understand.
Then I go back.
And so there are all these distractions.
So what do we do?
First of all, one very surprising thing is
I find that one of the best places for me
to focus is in an airplane where there's
noise there's people, but I'm stuck there.
So in a way, all of the noise
and the possible distractions
are not distractions.
I find that I'm able to do a lot of
reading and a lot of study on an airplane.
Uh, we had a programmer at
LingQ who did his best work...
he, we have a sort of what we call the
sky train, which is our public transit
system, which travels around above ground.
It's not underground.
And he would go on the sky train with
all of the distractions that were
there and he found himself better
able to concentrate and come up with
solutions in terms of programming.
So it's not obvious.
And I have said before that,
if I sit down, I want to listen
to something just to listen to
something I easily lose my focus.
Whereas if I'm doing the dishes
or in the car, I have some other
activity, uh, I'm better able to focus.
I know there are people who can
focus better in a, in a cafe with
all the distractions and the other
people than they can, kind of, at
home where they're on their own.
So sometimes the act of pushing other
distractions away can help us to focus.
I think everyone has to find
their own, you know, most,
you know, which environment is
more, most conducive to focus.
Uh, I think having a time
of the day, uh, is good.
So my listening is not
so much a focus activity.
I listen, I sometimes focus
sometimes don't focus.
I don't think it's a problem.
It's, it's free learning.
Cause it's a learning that happens
while I'm doing something else.
So I'm not attempting to learn
anything during that period.
I just know that it's beneficial
to be listening to whatever
it is I'm listening to.
But I try to have a certain period
of time and because I'm retired,
it can be in the afternoon.
Uh, I used to do it before going to
sleep, but that's a bit distracting
and I, I don't think it's good for
the brain to be trying very hard to
learn things just before going to bed.
And I think there is perhaps some truth
in the fact that, because I do a lot
of my learning on the iPad, that having
that electronic, those signals coming at
you is probably not good for your sleep.
So if I am going to study say Egyptian
Arabic or something, I will have, I have
a textbook, so or a book, a textbook.
And so I will look at the book
before going to sleep, but I don't,
I don't want to use my iPad before
going into that and going to sleep.
But for some people that could be
a period of time where they are
able to focus and concentrate.
Uh, I have said that with my listening,
which I do first thing in the morning,
that's another part of my routine.
I don't worry about my focus.
Uh, whatever I'm able to pick
up from my listening is good.
And I'll either be listening to my
mini story for the 35th time, or I'll
be listening to, uh, a news podcast
and, and getting something from that.
I don't worry about my focus there.
Um, this idea of, of distractions,
obviously, if we are still working
and we're interrupted and we're
checking our email or checking
our, uh, you know, messages,
obviously it's better to do that.
You know, save it until the
end of the hour or save it.
But these are things that so many
people have written about that you
can't be constantly checking your
Twitter feed, constantly checking
your emails or your messages.
You're better off to save that for a
period of time, do it in a, you know, in
a sort of a, a batch and then get back
so that your learning, your language
learning is uh, you know, a batch process
or spending time with your language,
and then the other duties that you
have, then they occur at a certain time.
Now I'm not saying anything there
that hundreds of other people haven't
said, not everyone can do that.
And obviously it's very tempting
to, uh, especially okay, the Olympic
games, uh, you know, whatever
your country is, how did we do?
In the middle of your studying, because
you, you can access and you go into.
So, you know, we can say don't do that.
And some people are going to do it.
Nevertheless, part of it is how
genuinely motivating is whatever
you're reading or listening to.
Uh, how committed are you to the
task at hand, if you're only casually
committed to the task, you'll be more
easily um, you know, distracted, if,
uh, if say you were, uh, you know, your
life depended upon learning something,
you would be totally motivated to
learn that you would stay on the task.
Uh, if, uh, you're very interested in
some aspect of Japanese, anime or whatever
it might be or, or, uh, Persian history
then yeah I'm going to stay on task.
If it's not interesting,
then I won't stay on task.
So focus is also a function of
how relevant, how interesting, how
compelling, whatever content you have is.
Now when you're speaking, of course,
I don't think focus is so much of an
issue, uh, because you're involved in a
conversation say with your tutor or your
tutor is going to ask you questions.
You're going to have to
respond to the question.
So focus there is not so much of an issue.
Focus becomes a bigger issue when you're
involved in what could be considered
passive activities like listening
and reading and your mind wanders.
And in today's day and age and the
internet, internet age, it's easy to be
distracted and allow your mind to wander.
So, uh, you know, all I can say really
is in my own case, I am distracted.
Uh, I think to some extent it's
a, it's a negative that goes with
all of the other advantages that
the internet age provides us.
So I accept that.
I think I beat off the, the impulse
to go and check a check up on my email
or my Twitter feed, uh, as best I can.
And sometimes I succumb.
But, you know, at the end of
the day, there's still a lot of
focused learning that takes place.
And I think we don't need to be
perfectionist when it comes to focus
and just try our best to focus as
best we can using whatever methods
work best with our lifestyle.
So that's really all I have to
say on the subject of focus.
So I hope that was useful.
Bye for now.